si j'étais une femme se serait emma
watson c'est un bon accent anglais alors
allez-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et shining men qui veut dire en anglais
[Applaudissements]
c'est une troupe de 30 artistes et 500
costumes magnifiques comme vous pouvez
le voir à part deux ils sont
représentation casino de paris en syrie
benjamin castaldi en tout cas ça nous va
très bien je sais qu'il ya votre femme
dans les coulisses l effet très je pense
qu'elle a dû qui fait à la doré ah non
mais franchement si vous deviez est une
personne de sexe au programme sur ye qui
a three marceau qui suit malsaucy la
pâte fimo libanais marceau dans les sept
centres slimane c'est pas la mandarine
veut non mais sérieux marceau qui fait à
je kiffe à mort ah ouais sauf mazères ma
famille ressemble un peu d'ailleurs
chaque femme à quai à slimani et qui
vous elle est même passé à ce nom
[Applaudissements]
la leïla
[Musique]
j'aimerais mettre votre épouse parce que
j'aurais aimé être un jour à la source
de la création j'aurais aimé un créateur
comme ça ou de dali voilà est à vos
côtés et voir tout le temps les
fulgurances vous avez vu ce qu'on
appelle le mozart du paf et voir comment
commence à se rebeller le un génie du
travail on va voir si j'étais une femme
se serait emma watson
emma watson les carrières de soi elle
est à la fois française et anglaise vrai
mais alors pas aussi t on au grand pas
du tout mais j'ai un bon accent anglais
alors allez-y
[Applaudissements]
très distinguée vous avez les versions
américaines c'est un peu plus jeune bébé
[Applaudissements]
ou sur les kivu mais omis campbell elle
a une belle carrière avons porté ces
dommages là il va changer parce que il
nous fait chier que le micro non mais
beaucoup pour acheter il faut enfin
ouais ouais très mimi mathy faut faire
comme ça a pu voir réguler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]